I want to ask you about this uh this
project this blows my mind and I love
that this is happening but you've
directed a couple of sketches for this
upcoming sketch Series history of the
World Part Two I saw a history of the
World Part One as a movie when it came
out I think I it was 1981. yeah 1981 so
I was a teenager this is four years
before moving to Los Angeles that's
right okay I would have been what 7 81 I
would have been 17 years old when that
movie came out and uh I was
you know huge as I am to this day huge
Mel Brooks fan and what amazes me and
I've had the opportunity to interview
him a number of times he is always funny
unfailingly funny yes uh one of the few
who uh who I can say that about and he
um
he he is now I think he's 96. he's 96.
and you're working with Mel Brooks on
this project which blows my mind that's
such a high honor it is uh it is a crazy
thing like I would say for me uh over
the years I would say you know SNL
obviously The Music Man episode from The
Simpsons and those are my biggest two
influences
um but truly I mean ethanol obviously
big but Mel Brooks uh those movies uh
really for me the the producers was my
favorite movie for from when I was like
13 yeah for many many years but Young
Frankenstein Blazing Saddles history of
the World Part One
um are hugely important to my comedy
development and and uh I became I've had
a meeting with Mel at his office and he
gave me a box of raisinets and it was
like the most amazing thing I've ever
experienced and
you know I love that I wonder if that's
uh I think he probably does it with
everybody I think that's great I I don't
know and but I but meeting him just
meeting him alone was truly incredible
and then I got a call uh being like Mel
wants to do history World part two he'd
like to do it with you and and
um and it's me and Ike Barenholtz and
Dave stas and his writing partner and
Wanda Sykes
um and and then an incredible group of
writers and performers are doing a
series for Hulu based off of you know
using the the movie as a a template
which is like historical sketch right
um and Mel narrates the show uh and and
I got to work with him I mean I got to
you know I he's he's so sharp and so
funny he's still got bits there's like
jokes throughout the show that are
pitches that he still has
um and he's it's like it's really the
most weird like the craziest thing that
for me I think I've ever experienced I
think uh there's something that
fascinates me about this generation uh
that I'm saying that generation of
uh comedian and I'm thinking about
uh you know Carl Reiner Mel Brooks
um Norman Lear
um Bob Newhart they're all these people
that uh live
you know well Norman Lear is now a
hundred I think Carl Reiner almost made
it to a hundred
um and uh
what blows my mind is when I've had the
opportunity to be around any of these
people
they are the funniest people in the room
and I always had this fear and I'll
admit this is Aegis but it's something
you worry about in comedy is do you does
it will you get less funny
your mind yeah will you be less amusing
as you get older will you lose touch and
I think these guys are as funny as
they've ever been and
uh I also believe
it is part of why they get why they're
so sharp and they're around so long yeah
I think there's something about laughing
every day and engaging with and being
around people that make you laugh that
some secret to longevity that no one's
cracked yet I think the and I mean I
guess it's the ones who were humorless
died younger as we can say that now
right yes yeah so anyone who died young
had no sense of humor exactly hi I'm
Conan O'Brien with a terrible Theory
that's completely unproven but James
Dean I didn't see a lot of people laugh
by the way genuinely not that funny
exactly I keep watching Giant and I'm
not laughing
um although have you seen the video of
him and Paul Newman having a screen test
oh was this part of the uh uh Paul
Newman uh Joanne Woodward uh documentary
may I don't know I didn't see that but
it's it's worth if again there's a way
I'm not gonna you guys know the website
to go to most of the things you're
plugging you don't have you're only
tangentially involved yes but it is you
see the chemistry between Paul Newman
and James Dean where you're like they
are gonna straight up
[ __ ] on camera right now it's crazy
watch it anyway yeah at any time of day
alone probably yeah so uh my point being
that Mel Brooks is a legend yeah uh no
um uh I agree I think that he stays
sharp when you see him he's he's I do
think that having continuing to have a
sense of humor finding people and I
think in the case of Mel and Carl they
were friends you know like they were
friends for 70 years and got together
three nights a week and watched movies
and and uh and and being able and that's
I mean that is the dream like you're
like you're you're dearest most favorite
people and friends in comedy in the
world that you continue to get together
and you continue to make each other
laugh and for me being able to just have
a moment we and he is still so funny
like we did it was over Zoom we did a
read through of a bunch of sketches with
the network and a bunch of people on Mel
I was there and and uh he goes I liked
uh I like the songs and I I liked some
of the Reeds
he's still just funny and nagging every
call every time and and and I just think
he he
um had an incredible palpable energy I
mean it's also those guys all those
people that you named I think we're all
like our all World War II vets they are
yeah which is crazy because you served
in you were in you were in Vietnam but
you didn't did you serve I went to a
hotel in Vietnam okay okay I think now
2006. okay it was a layover okay I was
on my way to Aspen okay it's a weird way
to get to Aspen because it was for the
festival yeah and um so I was wearing
all ski stuff really expensive douchey
ski stuff and I just uh I stepped off
the plane and checked into a hotel and
then got right out again but I thought
that gave me the right to say
you know me
um but they all went through real stuff
and then also have seen But Amel is also
an example as you were saying of like
when you go back and watch this through
the world part one
um he he's he's sort of very much it
felt you know to do a show about history
right now is a tricky thing a sketch
show
um comedically of being like how are we
gonna do this
um but you realize on some level Mel's
style was always poking fun at the
powerful and the rich and as like stupid
and greedy but it was never he's never
been very political right so like it was
it was actually not a it was actually a
very good template to sort of like how
do we do all this right now where you're
like sort of you know talking exposing
like the real history but also sort of
never taking itself too seriously yeah
and and I meld when you go back and
watch Mel stuff he's doing that so well
I think it's important to remember uh I
got to interview in a long format uh Mel
Brooks once and he was telling me this
story of he fought in World War II and
he was like on Sentry Duty and he could
hear the German across the river and
they were shouting insults at each other
back and forth and I'm talking and
you're thinking about well this is a you
know famous
uh Jewish American comedian one of the
greats of all time who who was there he
was he was the Nazis were on the other
side of the river and he was in uniform
and you think about Norman Lear flying
bomber missions I mean these guys uh
were part of the most epic struggle
against evil in the 20th century and
then also made some of the greatest
comedy it's uh I don't know it's uh I
can't get over it and it makes me
ashamed of myself face off against Mel
Brooks in an insult War yeah like the V2
rocket you know yeah I didn't even know
what they're up against yeah exactly no
I'm just I don't that's what I'm saying
like I don't uh
um I think it's time you and I did
something Brave to do another country
let's go to the the Rhine River let's go
now let's go now let's go now and we'll
take one of those boats that float
slowly along the Rhine and serves
delicious cheeses and wine and so yeah
well I mean yeah Mel Brooks did it and
so I did it with crawl yeah Crow and I
we went well I could be your enemy I
could be on one side of the river yeah
and you could be on there you could be
having dry whites and I could be having
richer Reds that's where we disagree you
[ __ ] in Lorraine I'm over here in
Alsace
is that how they pronounce it did I
pronounce it perfectly in the German
French I think it was fine it's done
it's fine we're done we're going to get
some calls now
I know I love to say we get calls yeah
why can't we just pretend we get calls
you can't even have a phone well can't
you just put in phone sound effects in
the background sometimes okay to call
the calls are lighting up yeah I'll do
it right now yeah
add calls to it whatever you're gonna do
I know this is Hans from outside I
wanted to talk about uh first time long
time
well Hans are you enjoying the show so
far so far it's okay it's not my
favorite episode I listen to your
podcast live every day
[Laughter]
crawl on today talking about outside and
did necro pronounce it correctly yes he
did but the Rhine River's not even close
to Elsa
as London Mark that out for you so you
know anyway don't you love people that
are that love to lured their knowledge I
live here and no no it's not there Bob
Newhart told me once in the original Bob
Newhart Show uh it opens with him uh
coming home from work he leaves the
office and uh
he walks through the streets of Chicago
and then he gets on an elevated train
and then you see him get off the train
and then you see him walk and he goes to
the apartment and comes in and Suzanne
pleshette's there and it's that's the
that's the opening of the show and he
said for years
people would come up to him who were
from Chicago and like you know something
I gotta tell you something there Bob uh
you know you get on you get on the L you
know over by the loop it doesn't take
you from there over you're like
you know that it didn't actually work
out and I remember uh doing that to I
was at SNL as a writer and we watched an
episode of Spencer for Spencer for Hire
was just on TV and the only reason I
turned it on was someone told me our
high school was in it and they shot an
episode where Spencer Robert Urich is
running through the high school like to
try and find a bomb and I'm there
watching it with the other writers and I
went
oh you can't get from a wing to the
cafeteria
unless you take the north stairs but
they like cut and suddenly and everyone
looked over at me and suddenly I
realized that I was a horrible horrible
man and deserve to die and uh and then
you did that day I died that day very
young proving once again I'm not funny